so she heard you and what I love what
you just did now for everyone in this
audience your departed loved ones hear
you so know that she needs you to know
that she did not intentionally take her
own life do you understand that she was
a very spiritual
person and there's a lot
of there hasn't been a funeral there
hasn't been Memorial there hasn't been
anything hasn't been like a
closure because we didn't find out till
later that she passed I have a hard time
with closure okay okay because to me
that's so final what she has just did
was just say to you let the Justice be
that my soul is at peace with God how do
you connect with the Stars or the clouds
or do you look at the clouds and you see
things that remind you of her like they
form into a shape cuz she just showed me
a heart and out of a out of a I have a
heart-shaped Stone in my yoga bag that I
carry with me every validate when you
look at the sky when you know that that
is her with you at that exact moment do
you understand that